hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse RN calm and in this video we're
going to go over how to do a quality
control on your glucometer what is the
quality control a quality control is the
solution that you get with your
glucometer whenever you buy it and also
nursing students in the clinical setting
you'll be doing glucometer tests or QC
control test on your glucometer on the
floor and it's just to make sure that
the machine is calibrated dry and it's
working correctly so you get the right
glucose readings so typically whenever
you have a home monitor you'll want to
check do a quality control before you
use your new monitor any time you change
out your test strips and periodically
throughout the week just to make sure
that your blood sugars are reading crack
EULA correctly say that you have been
checking your blood sugars and they've
been running really high and that's not
normal for you may want to do a quality
control test or they've been running
really low you may just want to check it
make sure it's working good and the
number that you get on your home monitor
should correspond to whatever your guide
says it should run for so always refer
to your how to use your glucometer
manual to make sure that your glucometer
is working the best because some
monitors work a little bit differently
but in this video I'm going to
demonstrate how to do it so let's get
started okay for your quality control
let's go over some basic things first
your test strips remember to always make
sure you're using test strips that have
not expired so look at the date on the
strips and any time you open these
strips they're only good for four months
and after that discard them because they
could give you false readings and just
write right here what when you open them
and when they expire now your QC test
your quality control solution is good
for three months and always make sure
that it's not expired now anytime you
use your quality control solution you
need to make sure it's mixed correctly
never shake this okay how you do it you
roll it in between your hands like so
just to get it all good mixed and the
it's ready to use so what you do and
with this specific monitor we can turn
it on here or just insert the test strip
it's easier to insert the test strip so
we're going to do that
and what we will do is we will put this
part inside the monitor right there and
then this part will suck up the solution
just like if you were collecting a blood
droplet from your finger so I'm going to
insert this into the device and the
device will turn on on some monitors you
will have to go and hit a button to
change it to the control setting to let
it know you're doing a control but with
this specific monitor I can just apply
the control solution so always check
with your user manual so what we're
going to do we've already mixed our
solution and I'm just going to turn it
this way so I can get to it and what
we'll do is we will take the cap off and
we will just do it little drop right
where you would put your blood okay and
it'll just suck it up just like that and
let's see what it says okay it says 46
now when I look in my monitor user guide
it will tell me because there's usually
three different control levels you have
a lot of glucometers recommend you get
all three this is a level one and it
tells me what number level one should
run through and this is within the range
some glucometers are a little bit
fancier and they'll just tell you passed
so either way as long as your glucometer
is calibrated right you are good to go
so that is how you do a quality control
on a glucometer be sure to check out my
other videos on how to check your blood
sugar on how to load a Lancet device and
how to use a Lancet device and please
subscribe to this youtube channel and
thank you so much for watching